this is foreign policy chinese style
planting their flag at the bottom of the
South China Sea it's a show of force in
one of the world's most contentious
territorial disputes these are rich
fishing grounds but also an area of
Mineral Resources many countries make
claims to the area but China has the
upper hand it's built military bases on
atolls unsinkable outposts in the middle
of the ocean at the shangri-la dialogue
conference there are concerns about
Chinese saber rattling we all know
there's no military solution to the
South China Sea disputes right now at
this critical juncture that it is time
for renewed diplomacy focused on finding
a lasting solution but that's easier
said than done when the negotiating
table is this crowded six countries lay
claim to the South China Sea and half
the world's cargo ships pass through the
area the US says free passage must be
guaranteed if necessary through military
force China seems unimpressed it says
because other countries stake a claim to
the sea then restrained can't only be
demanded of the Chinese this was their
reply to the US Secretary of Defense
criticize the China's construction
activities I think your criticism is
grand the leash and not constructive I
think in a few expected a breakthrough
in the talks but in bilateral talks
Japan and China took a small step
towards reducing tensions over their
maritime disputes they want to set up a
joint hotline aimed at preventing
military conflict escalating at sea